The Amazing Digital Circus is an
immensely popular indie animated series
that went viral immediately upon its
October 2023 release, accumulating over
300 million views on its pilot episode
in just a few months. The series has
garnered over a billion total views as
of late 2025. It is known for its
high-quality animation, dark humor, and
widespread appeal, including a massive
presence on TikTok. If you have children
with access to the internet or Netflix,
I guarantee that they have heard of this
show or have watched it themselves. You
may have even bought them one of the
toys from Walmart in the children's
section or even set them in front of
this show yourself, unaware of what it
was teaching them. Like many other
mainstream movies and shows that have a
gnostic storyline, such as The Matrix,
The Truman Show, Pleasantville, Ugly
Dolls, Smallfoot, Lego Movie, and many
more, this series tells the same story.
A story that tells an inversion of the
Bible where God is a villain and Satan
is the hero, where eternity in a perfect
world is dreaded and rebellion against
God is the only way to freedom. A female
figure named Pomni enters a digital
world where she is immediately
introduced to a being named Caine. She
is told that he is the creator and that
he has given her a new home, a new body,
and a new name.
>> What do you think of Pomni? Welcome to
your new home and your new body. This is
exactly what's going to happen when we
enter heaven. We will all have a new
home. We will have new bodies, and God
will give us a new name. She's told that
in this world anything is possible
except swearing. Well, anything can
happen except for swearing.
We can't have any of that foul language
around here. The Amazing Digital Circus
is a place to be enjoyed by all ages.
Caine tells Pomni that this is a place
suitable for all ages, a wholesome
place. There are many hints dropped in
the pilot episode that they are in fact
in heaven and that Caine is God. Ah, you
must be the brave knight sent to us by
God to help us with our recent
catastrophe. That's us, ma'am. We even
see a scene of all the inhabitants
sitting on one side of a long table
imitating the Last Supper. In one
episode, we see Caine acting as a
therapist to one of the characters,
saying that he has to get to the bottom
of their behavioral issues. We need to
get to the bottom of your behavioral
issues. The inhabitants are praised for
choosing the pacifist route, saying that
they should be proud of the good people
that they are. Congratulations!
You've taken the pacifist route, and you
should be PROUD OF WHAT GOOD PEOPLE you
are. We're told in this perfect place
that there are many rooms to sleep in,
but no one needs to sleep. Where we all
sleep [music] at night, even though we
don't really need to sleep.
>> This is exactly how Jesus describes
heaven in John 14:2 when he says, "In my
father's house are many rooms, and I go
to prepare a place for you." Throughout
the episodes, you find out that in this
world you cannot die. Well, you can't
exactly die. It's like the whole thing
here. That sex is forbidden. I want the
ability to have sex.
And that there's no escape from this
eternal world of rules. So, everyone is
incentivized to follow the rules and
trust each other. Those who seek an
escape from this world of rules become
abstracted, which basically means to be
possessed, and they are sent [music]
down below to the cellar of darkness.
And into the cellar you go.
They are told that anything outside of
this circus tent is a void. He makes it
known that he sees everything with his
all-seeing eyes.
>> We stay right here, where I can keep my
hundreds of all-seeing eyes on you.
And if someone in this digital world
begins to glitch, the only one that can
save them is Caine, the creator. Find
Caine. He'll be able to fix me up and
take take care of Caine and Pomni.
To keep people from getting bored in
eternity in a world full of rules, Caine
gives people adventures. Today's
adventure is
GATHER THE GLOINKS.
>> [laughter]
>> AND THESE ADVENTURES ARE live-action
role-playing games. The idea being
propagated to the viewer is that
eternity is something to be dreaded,
that rules are meant to be broken, and
that God is not to be worshipped but to
be rebelled against and ultimately
killed. Pomni's role in the series is to
be the awakener. Her whole arc is built
around rejecting the creator's world,
distrusting his motives, seeking hidden
truth, gaining power, and helping lead
the revolt. From the very beginning, she
is seeking an exit, but over and over
the exit door is removed before she can
enter through it. She's even told by
Caine that the exit door she saw was a
digital hallucination and doesn't even
exist. I assure you there is no magical
exit door. You're probably just
experiencing DIGITAL HALLUCINATIONS.
The creator of this digital world of
rules is painted as a gaslighting
tyrannical maniac, and Pomni's character
is to awaken those who are in this world
that they are in a prison and need to
escape, just like the rebellion Lucifer
started in heaven. Each episode is full
of foul language, which is censored by
Caine himself, as well as themes of
horror and psychologically mind-bending
plots. Though the creator of The Amazing
Digital Circus says that the show
targets audiences ages 13 and up, you
can clearly see by the marketing that
the toys end up in the children's
section of Walmart. There have even been
unofficial theatrical shows that fill
the auditorium with children. And in the
comments section, you can see that fans
clearly say this show is not for kids,
but they usually just laugh about it.
This is the type of mentality that's
being formed by young impressionable
minds that are consuming this type of
material full of dark humor. Recently,
there's been some debate about what age
you can begin watching The Amazing
Digital [music] Circus. This led to some
of the cast and crew weighing in. Let me
explain. So, yesterday over on Twitter,
one user posted a tweet that reads, "My
parents put this on for my 6-year-old
brother. I tried to tell them it wasn't
age-appropriate, and when Gummigoo got
eviscerated, he screamed and cried for
like 30 minutes." This tweet quickly
went viral, getting over 100,000 likes.
Gooseworx responded with, "Get good,
lol." Caine's voice actor, Alex Rochon,
said, "Oops, did I do that?" And the
official glitch account said, "Good."
Honestly, I think this is hilarious.
Episode 8 just dropped less than a week
ago, and the mask completely came off in
the story. Caine fully reveals that he
is a villain, and he openly declares
that he is God. I
AM
GOD.
>> [screaming and groaning]
>> BY THE END OF THE EPISODE, Pomni tells
God exactly how she feels about him. We
think your idea sucks. Huh? You don't
care about us at all. You care more
about stroking your own ego than giving
us anything we'd actually enjoy. You're
a failure. We're all going to abstract
someday, [music]
and what will you have then? Stop that.
>> And this whole stunt torturing us
because we hurt your feelings? Pathetic.
What kind of all-powerful being has such
a fragile ego? You don't comfort anyone
when they're upset, and you never
bothered to understand what it's like in
our shoes. You discourage us from
thinking outside the box and doing
things our own way. You lie to us
constantly.
>> And on top of it all, you just don't
listen. They end the episode by killing
the creator to obtain the freedom to do
all the lawless, debaucherous acts that
they please, including swearing for the
first time uncensored. Wait.
I think I accidentally killed Caine.
Holy
Satan is painting God as some distant
being that doesn't hear your prayers,
and all he cares about is worship
because he's some egotistical maniac,
but that couldn't be farther from the
truth. He literally sent his son to die
for you and to offer you eternal life in
a perfect world that will never get
boring. It'll never be dull. In a place
where there's no more thieves, no
adultery, no murders, no pain. That's a
world that I long to live in, but Satan
has deceived so many people to think
that life isn't fun unless you're
cussing or fornicating or doing drugs or
doing all the wicked things of this
world. Satan started the rebellion in
heaven over God's character, saying that
God was hiding something from them, that
God was keeping the other angels from
being able to evolve into godhood, that
he was keeping them from thinking
outside the box, as this show said. And
then he came to Earth as a serpent to
beguile Eve and tell her the same lie,
that God is keeping knowledge from you,
that you can evolve and be like God. And
he's out here telling his side of the
story in a million different forms of
entertainment. The only way to spot the
counterfeit is to study the truth like
never before. The truth will set you
free. Learn the truth. Teach it to your
children so that they can identify these
things and so that they can make an
informed decision
>> [music]
>> to turn this stuff off.
Cain the Truth.